non perderti anita stories la serie
animata un nuovo episodio ogni domenica
alle 12 sul mio canale vita bottoni
verità io parlerò e solidale oggi nuova
challenge che c'avete consigliato poi
farò shopping bendata su amazon per
berlina quindi contro una volta che
arriveranno le facciamo vedere un
berlina e vediamo qual è quella che vi
piace di più fd sono piaciute insomma
queste cose che ho comprato età bendata
berlino sarà comunque il nostro
assistente quindi abbiamo il computer un
berlino vuole tacere tutto e andrò a ben
d'armi evitare contro la che sto clicca
questo del maschio è più basse per dire
ora controllando che facciamo
correttamente la challenge si fa allora
c'è una difficoltà tecniche a berlino ha
deciso di sdraiarsi davanti al computer
qui allora prendi confermato 400 e così
possiamo iniziare la challenge nel
frattempo berlino farà insomma da
testimone
ecco che si gira e controlla anche lui
il computer bravo bravo anche mi deve
controllare
allora vado a ben d'armi proprie
possiamo iniziare la challenge
io però il mouse pad altra parte vitale
controllerà se starò cliccando qualcosa
area
ok allora scendo 100 100 100 e stop ho
cliccato qualcosa no ci sei quasi rai
abbiamo aggiunto al carrello anche terra
nella pagina principale siamo tornati
nella pagina principale che siamo già
nella sezione cani altrimenti non
avremmo mai trovato cose per cani nella
pagina principale
ma io vi maggio tocca poi cento senza
[ __ ] sta salendo
sì non è cliccato niente ci si decida
però le date 16 sulla barra laterale
click
sempre sulla barra laterale punti cisco
storia spezzata
si vero per esempio sulla barra laterale
dove stare un po a destra adesso troppo
ha detto no ancora no ma giuste
cliccando niente adesso stai per
chiudere la pagina seclì cilic adesso
andiamo piano quella della doppietta di
berlino non puoi cliccare la zampa
adesso ci sei quasi click
ancora adesso cliccato
qualche aspetto che ci sono tre modelli
come tre colori no sono tre modelli non
so se sono grandezza e grandezze questa
è la grandezza più grande forlì non sarà
contento il carrello carrello
ok sono tornato indietro o che
ovviamente peso di mary caridi ha
lasciato un bel mi piace se volete una
seconda parte o altri video shopping
bendata se questo video raggiunge i 15
mila mi piace saremo un secondo video
shopping bendata consigliati oppure che
negozio o che cosa volete che facciamo e
berlino sarà super contento sei una
challenge per lui il vero non vi sta
muovendo
si ok click sull'articolo ma non è
cliccato qui ho cliccato la pec e perché
no no ok e cliccate cliccata cliccato
allora devo dire che ha scelto una cosa
molto carina ma c'è solo un voto ed è
pessimo quindi sarebbe persino siete ci
sono tre colori se non sbaglio quindi
celeste c'è blu blu blu perché per
merlino la sua i giochi seletti blu si
abbinano dei suoi occhi
ma c'è anche verde verde un verde c'è
scritto verde per il verde carino no no
è un celeste la chiave cablo buffon
ragione era mary celeste e cenette il
celeste per quello che c'è scritto verde
perché però e celeste se celeste va bene
ma lo deve essere verde che perdiamo va
bene non lo metto blusa e perché ormai
deciso gliel'ho detto blu ok
e siamo a tre articoli ok allora adesso
tenuto bene re adesso puoi passare alla
seconda pagina questi ci sono giochi di
verdi si ok ok ok ok come si fa tornare
indietro
se io siamo alla seconda pazzi servizio
la seconda pagina
ok
allora corre corre corre berlino sto
studiando anche il computer ho cliccato
sguardo si è molto vicina non è cliccato
da click free trade che ce la posso fare
qua c'è la cosa river lire meta
applicato qualcosa no non è così che la
stretta indicato cliccato ha gettato un
gioco per berlino aggiungo si aspetta
aspetta di trovare una pagina volontà ok
ok abbiamo raggiunto il nostro quarto
gioco giusta sì abbiamo oggetto quarto
del quarto giovane ok direi di ora mi
spendo non si vede niente
allora abbiamo aggiunto un altro quarto
gioco per il nostro cagnolino bellissimo
ora andiamo a procedere con ordine
[Musica]
facciamo un viaggio nel tempo il nostro
pacco sarà già qua e vediamo berlino
come reagirà e io sono super curioso di
vedere che cosa ho preso da bendata a
berlino sono controllate pronti per il
nostro viaggio nel tempo circolare con
che berlino allora infatti questi giochi
sono arrivati merlino stylist andò
monopolizzare la scena vuole sempre
essere in primo piano
allora andiamo ad aprire il primo pacco
che questa puzza sicuri horror furioso
furiosissimo allora vediamo cosa il
secco a berlino allora merlino e
assonnato appunto perché l'abbiamo
portato a fare una passeggiatina è
perché dopo pranzo lui dopo project
rotondo e devo dormire quindi non sarà
super agitato come saprete che sbaglia
sempre è una specie di pallina anche per
me queste sono delle sorprese perché non
so cosa ho preso allora sia una mini
pallina che questa non so se va bene
dargliela perché ho paura che se arriva
ma insomma
in realtà questo gioco qui è un gioco
che volevamo già prendere e cosa fai
carlino impazzirà complesso abbiamo
visto una pubblicità in pratica che si
attacca con la ventosa e il cane avuto
lotina vediamo se funziona allora
praticamente questa è una super ventosa
che va attaccata è subito arrivato
aspettano non si attacca berlino già
troppo pulita ma forse devo schiacciarla
ok ok qui diamo da berlino è un po
mielose sbagliato vi diamo è in pratica
chi deve tirare la pallina ma la pallina
non si tira perché è attaccata con la
mente un calcio non so se si è capito
dalla mia spiegazione
comunque sembra che gli piace ciao molto
vediamo si sa se si stacca berlino
adesso stacca pure la mattonella dai
tiromancino di averli ridotti ai genere
ti rende pro le corde ma adesso è troppo
felice per la nuova pallina vediamo xena
tv rimane davvero si ventilava minuti a
via
muscoli bruciano tirare le punizioni
dell'amore fantastico questo gioco
perché berlino ad ora tirare la corda
quindi ogni volta viene a prendere la
corda c'è la porta e vuole che gliela
tiriamo per mezz'ora adesso potrà tirare
come se vuole anche se secondo me questa
pallina durerà molto plastichina però
l'idea dell'avvento nata l'idea della
ventosa che tiene la corda è geniale
ok mentre marino gioca tutto nuovo gioco
che già mi piace tantissimo
tra l'altro alla fine del video dovrete
dirsi qual è il vostro preferito e
vedremo qual è il profilo di marino
vediamo di altri giochi è preso da 28 a
stesso super curiosa allora per qualcosa
senza guardare bene è un pupazzino a
queste kong lui ha già avuto pupazzetto
kong allora diamo vederlo che era un
manicotto un fenicottero e l'ha
distrutto ovviamente praticamente questi
pupazzetti sono un po diversi perché
dentro hanno delle corde infatti anche
l'altro li avevamo comprato hanno delle
corde dentro fine man mano che lui lo
distrugge trovati d'accordo speriamo che
duri un po di più questo remo che duri
più di un giorno
[Musica]
carino consumo berlino stituto nuovo
pacchetto che aspetta che ti tolgo la
confezione il nuovo pezzetto stacchiotti
piano questo mettiamo a cavallo di
berlino che forse kyoto che felicità ma
si può credere che ha degli uomi giochi
da di mangiucchiare sembrati piazza
molta impediamo vediamo se gli piace di
più questo perché eri piazza più loquaci
altre anche se questo gioco è davvero
geniali vado a cercare il prossimo gioco
è qualcosa di strano questo mondo mi
sembra mosso nostro meglio
c'è questo caso era venduto nei negozi
per giocattoli di per cani devil e india
l'albero un pezzo di legno si in realtà
il mio vero
in realtà siro vendono anche nel negozio
di animali questi legni speciali del
cane per scanu pelarli esatto proprio
perché sono altri resistenti è il
profumo di foresta ma non so se a
berlino piacerà questa cosa abbiamo
erano chiare quindi diamo
attendiamo le etichette berlino si sta
continuando a mantenere il suo
orsacchiotto un po troppo grande per
altro buco e vi piacete ranocchia che il
tramonto durare anche questo anzi forse
questo durerà un posizione che mi sembra
più resistente sembra molto contento
berlino di sgranocchiare lui adora
sgranocchiare le cose e che carino ma
felici
ok prossimo gioco che dovrebbe essere
l'ultimo prendiamo un altro un falsetto
ho paura che mi diranno molto vale quel
tipo pazzelli ecco ma è una specie di
pulsanti rodigan abbiamo sì interessati
così
ora andiamo l'etichetta quando comunque
super carino guardo anche l'abbandono
qua mi dispiace che verrà distrutto da
berlino sembra un gioco per cani ce
l'hai scritto che era resistente loro
esperimento non penso proprio che
resisterà a furia di berlino si creano
infatti sembra molto interessato a quel
di berlino sembra che difesa più il
pezzo di legno
secondo me sì sto scrivendo anche a
barre che questa guerra perché gli piace
a posto anche quei berlino ora andremo a
mettere i quattro giochi in fila e
vediamo merlino quale preferisce ok ecco
qua ho posizionato tutti e quattro i
giocati ora entrerà mellino vediamo
quale preferisce via viviamo per
compreso l'orsacchiotto per primo scrivi
forse quello è il suo preferito vediamo
se ci ripensa sembrano tutti quello sia
il suo preferito immerge a me quello che
è piaciuto di più è questo e geniale con
la ventosa ecco merlino che è pages
sappia si giochino vi infatti
e davvero super felice se è troppo
freddo che ha saputo che con te mi
sembra che bello non mi ha cambiato idea
il suo preferito sia solamente un
semplice cioè il pezzettino di lei ci
sono gran occhiali della passione che ci
fa a berlino
guarda dopo aver detto di legno dal
tiranno chiare mentre berlino si
sgranocchia il suo giochino noi siamo
qua quattro cartellini su cui cliccare
per vedere i nostri altri video cliccate
su quella che preferite e buona visione
ciao
[Musica]